Wenn ich so zurückschaue,
weiss ich noch,
wie ich am ersten Morgen, als alles
losging, beim Aufstehen dachte:
Puh.
Und, wie wär's,
einen Sommer auf der Alp zu arbeiten?
Es ist so wie erwartet.
Ein bisschen anstrengender.
* Explosionsgeräusch *
Komm, komm.
Alpromantik ist etwas,
was noch viele reizt.
Mit solchen Bildern fördere ich
diese Romantik natürlich auch.
Ich mache jetzt Feierabend.
- Nein, jetzt w...
Wie ist es, den Bürojob
mit dem Stallalltag zu tauschen?
Das Powernap fehlt mir heute
schon ein bisschen, muss ich sagen.
Ein Abenteuer ausserhalb
der Komfortzone auf 2'000 m ü.M.
Haha, whoohoo!
Es klingt wirklich
wie der einfachste Job der Welt.
Ich weiss nicht,
ob ich dir das zutraue.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Ich fahre für ein paar Tage
auf die Belalp oberhalb von Brig/VS.
Jetzt dürft ihr nicht lachen.
Aber ich habe mich auch schon dabei
ertappt, dass ich dachte:
"Einmal einen Sommer auf der Alp, das
wäre doch schön. Mach das doch mal."
Obwohl ich wirklich
zu 100 % unqualifiziert bin.
Diese Alpromantik
ist sehr ansteckend.
Genau darum geht es in diesem Film.
Wie romantisch ist es tatsächlich
und wie sieht die Realität aus?
Wir treffen Raffi und Beat,
sie sind dieses Jahr
zum ersten Mal auf der Alp.
Eigentlich
haben sie einen ganz anderen Job.
Ich bin gespannt,
wie sie sich diesen Sommer schlagen.
Und das ist diesen Sommer
ihr Arbeitsort.
Kaum bin ich hier,
kann ich gleich wieder umdrehen.
Gehen wir zu Fuss?
- Du nimmst das Velo. - Schon, oder?
Es ist Zeit,
um die Kühe vom Feld zu holen.
* Kuhglocken *
Untendurch, hier kommen sie runter.
Die erste Lektion
lerne ich sehr schnell,
fit muss man sein,
wenn man effizient von A nach B will.
* Keuchen *
(Keuchend) Die anderen gehen den Berg
wie eine Bergziege hoch.
Das ist unser ganzes Reich.
Bis zu diesem Grat, da vorne hin ...
Dort können sie
theoretisch bis zum Gletscher hoch.
Das machen sie aber natürlich nicht.
Dann da oben durch, bis dort oben.
Raffi will etwas wissen.
Raffael.
Wo bist du?
Siehst ... Das Grisighorn
hast du nicht gesehen?
Dann haben sie den Fleck aufgegeben.
Aber die Einzelkinder
sind schon irgendwo hinten.
Das war noch jedes Mal so.
Wie es dann halt manchmal ist.
Läuft alles gut, kommen alle
von alleine. Dann ist es tipptopp.
Friede, Freude, Eierkuchen.
Läuft irgendetwas schief,
kommt das andere gleich auch noch.
Dann macht man irgendeinen Fehler,
der dann plötzlich ...
Dann nimmt es einen.
Aber bis jetzt ...
- Das ist noch nie passiert?
Ähm, so Mitte Sommer einmal.
Da war es wirklich
ein bisschen anstrengend,
wir haben viel gemacht und gemerkt,
wie es sich ansammelt.
Aber wir konnten uns
dann tatsächlich so einrichten,
dass sie für mich schauen.
Und einen Morgen
konnte ich wirklich ausschlafen.
Ich habe geschlafen,
geschlafen, geschlafen,
gefrühstückt und wieder geschlafen.
Das war wie ein Reboot,
das war schon gut, glaube ich.
Überlegt man sich das,
bevor man auf die Alp geht?
Ob man das mit der Arbeit schafft?
Du arbeitest jeden Tag,
hast während 100 Tagen nicht frei.
Du stehst jeden Tag um 4 Uhr auf,
das ist megabelastend für den Körper,
nehme ich an, auch wenn man sich
ein bisschen daran gewöhnt.
Hast du dir das nie überlegt,
bevor du hierhergekommen bist?
"Kann ich das? Soll ich das können?"
Hm ...
Natürlich denkt man darüber nach,
aber ich denke ...
Einerseits ist es die Naivität,
vielleicht ist es besser,
dass man nicht so genau weiss,
was auf einen zukommt.
Worüber man am meisten nachdenkt,
ist ...
Rein physisch
kann man das schon machen.
Wenn es zäh ist,
beisst man die Zähne zusammen.
Die grosse Frage ist,
wie sehr das auf die Moral schlägt.
Dass man plötzlich
den Koller bekommt
und mental nicht mehr kann.
Beat
ist auf einem Bauernhof aufgewachsen.
Auch wenn er heute als Ingenieur
arbeitet, kennt er sich im Stall aus
und ist auch auf der Alp
kein kompletter Anfänger.
* Kuhglocken *
Raffi ist sein Mitbewohner
und guter Freund.
Von Beruf ist er ebenfalls Ingenieur
und hatte vor diesem Sommer
nicht viel Erfahrung
auf einem solchen Betrieb.
Zusammen mit zwei Käserinnen
schmeissen sie die Alp.
* Laute Kuhglocken *
- Etwas schöner könnten sie sein.
Priis, gut Glück.
- Erfolgreiches Melken.
Vor dem Alpaufzug ging er in einem
Stall ein paar Tage in die Lehre.
Der Rest ist learning by doing,
wie hier, wo rund 75 Kühe mit der
Melkmaschine verbunden werden müssen.
Nebenbei haben sie
noch Schweine und Hühner.
* Laute Kuhglocken *
Du, Raffi. - Ja?
- Es ist ja interessant:
Du hast ja gar keinen Hintergrund
in Landwirtschaft, zero.
Keinen aktiven.
Meine Grosseltern waren Bauern.
Als Kind habe ich es mitbekommen,
aber aktiv sehr wenig, ja.
Aber das ist ja der Witz
dieser ganzen Geschichte,
an dieser ganzen Reportage.
Leute denken: "Das wäre schön,
mal ein bisschen bauern und so."
Und du bist genau so einer.
Der Städter-Ingenieur, der sagt:
"Komm, ich habe Lust, zu bauern."
Ja, also ich habe es schon ...
Also im Vergleich zu anderen ...
... wusste ich schon vorher,
was Bauern bedeutet. - Ja.
Das ist schon ein Unterschied.
Ich war dabei,
als sie morgens früh aufstanden.
Ich bekam mit, was es heisst,
nicht in die Ferien zu fahren,
kein Wochenende zu haben.
Wenn wir am Sonntag zu Besuch waren,
musste die Arbeit gemacht sein.
Ich wusste, worauf ich mich
einlasse. Und jetzt bin ich hier.
Mittendrin. Und?
Es ist geil.
Genau ... Also, es ist so,
wie ich es erwartet habe.
Ein wenig anstrengender.
Ja, vielleicht ein wenig
anstrengender, mehr Arbeit.
Aber es hat mich nicht schockiert.
Hey, ich muss die Kühe abhängen,
sonst ...
Die Kühe sind gemolken, bis jetzt ist
der Tag relativ problemlos verlaufen.
Das ist wohl nicht immer so,
wie mir Beat und Raffi erzählt haben.
Mal schauen, was noch ansteht.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich merke schnell: Auf der Alp
gibt es immer etwas zu tun.
Komm mal.
Anscheinend läuft ein Kalb
irgendwo herum, wo es nicht sollte.
Schau, wir haben heute eine schöne
Marge. Aber die brauchen wir nun.
Freust du dich?
Wir müssen noch die Säue machen,
schauen, wo das Kalb hinkommt,
wem es gehört.
Haben wir wirklich ein Kalb?
- Dort läuft es einer Kuh hinterher.
Sicher nicht.
Das könnte eins von uns sein.
Jemand muss nachschauen.
Und ...
Bei der Bahn oben hast du die Ziegen
gesehen, oder? - Ja.
Weisst du, was unser Problem ist?
Die Ziegen reissen mit den Hörnern
das Futter auf und fressen es.
Wir haben also keine andere Wahl,
als das heute Abend zu machen.
Ja, also ...
- Ja. - Sehr geil.
Ich würde sagen, du gehst
Stinky holen und ich mache die Säue.
Dann holen wir möglichst schnell
das Futter.
Und dann schauen wir ...
- Erst ein Schnupf.
Ja, wenn es so anstrengend wird.
Wie viel Uhr ist es?
- 18 Uhr.
D.h., wir müssen
in einer halben Stunde oben sein.
Raffi, hast du kein Problem damit,
dass Beat den Chef raushängen lässt?
Nein.
- Er hat keine Wahl.
Nein. Erstens macht er es gut
und zweitens ...
... hört er zu, wenn ich Nein sage.
- Balsam ...
Balsam für die Seele.
- Das ist kein Problem.
Es ergibt Sinn. An die Ziegen
hatte ich nicht gedacht.
Das ist natürlich scheisse.
- Das Kalb wäre nicht so ...
Komm, Priis.
Das Powernap fehlt mir heute
schon ein bisschen, muss ich sagen.
Ich merke es ein bisschen.
- Morgen fehlt es dir dann.
Morgen kommt es dann
richtig darauf an. Priis.
Mit Raffi muss ich die Sachen
schon etwas ausdiskutieren.
Will er nicht?
- Ja, er ist halt einfach ...
Er ist Ingenieur, will sicher sein,
dass es die beste Lösung ist.
Wirklich?
- Ja.
Aber ich diskutiere ja gerne,
ich bin vom selben Schlag.
Ich habe ja gelernt,
mich zu verteidigen.
Ja, jetzt muss ich kurz ...
Heute ist etwas später Feierabend
als sonst.
Nur eine Frage ist noch offen: Wurde
von ihnen unbemerkt ein Kalb geboren?
Von der Bank oberhalb des Stalles
haben sie klare Sicht auf die Wiese
mit den Kühen, die bald kalben.
Na, Daniela.
Eins, zwei,
drei, vier, fünf, sechs ...
... sechs, sieben.
Ich sehe bereits sieben.
Hast du die dort gesehen?
- Ein Verlust ist schon drin, oder?
Ganz links, die Dunkelbraune.
Siehst du die?
Ist dahinter nicht noch eine?
- Ja, zehn.
Zehn. Sehr gut.
Hat eine davon ein Kalb dabei?
Ich habe sie wieder verloren.
- Heimatland.
Wir sagen jetzt einfach Nein.
Wir können es uns nicht leisten,
dort ein Kalb zu holen.
Ich fände es irgendwie noch geil.
Na ja ...
- Hä?
* Beat seufzt. *
Ich mache jetzt Feierabend.
- Nein, jetzt w...
Drei Monate lang hier zu zweit ...
Hattet ihr nicht etwas Angst
um eure Freundschaft?
Du schon? Nein.
- Nein. Nein, Angst nicht.
Überhaupt nicht.
- Also Angst, im Sinn von ...
Also ich dachte schon: "Der Typ
wird mich irgendwann nerven."
Aber irgendwie ...
... kriegt er es noch nicht hin.
Nein.
Du hast es probiert, oder?
- Ich gebe mir schon Mühe.
Ich glaube, wir sind zu alt,
um wütend aufeinander zu sein.
Wahrscheinlich. Oder zu müde.
- Zu müde.
Das gibt es natürlich schon,
dann ist man in einer Situation ...
Aber das sind so ...
Das ist so trivial, keine Ahnung.
Ich fing an, oben einzuzäunen, Beat
unten, weil er es für besser hielt.
Wenn es vielleicht
nicht so gut läuft
und der andere Unsinn macht
oder nicht mitdenkt,
denkt man schon:
"Komm, gib dir einen Ruck."
Ja ...
Aber wir sagen es einander sehr
schnell, wenn uns etwas nicht passt.
Mhm.
Das haben wir wirklich
noch nicht hinbekommen.
Einander so richtig auf den Sack
zu gehen? - Ja. Oder schon?
Nein.
Morgen ist ja auch noch ein Tag.
Einen wunderschönen guten Morgen.
Oder Nacht, I don't know.
Es ist kurz nach 4 Uhr morgens
und ...
Das ist die Zeit, zu der Älpler -
jedenfalls unsere Älpler -
aufstehen müssen, um melken zu gehen.
Ja.
Das alleine ist schon ein Grund,
warum ich das nie machen würde.
Jeden Tag, ohne Ausnahme,
drei Monate lang
um 4 Uhr aufzustehen,
um die Kühe zu melken.
Crazy.
Ja, mal schauen.
* Leise Kuhglocken *
Hallo!
- Morgen.
Morgens wird hier im Stall
nicht viel geredet.
Die Älpler purzeln
direkt aus dem Bett zum Melken.
Kaffee gibt es erst später.
Das Aufstehen ist nicht so sch...
Also,
die ersten 30 Sek. sind grausam.
Aber dann geht es.
Man merkt immer wieder:
Hier sind zwei Ingenieure am Werk.
Überall wird ein bisschen optimiert,
z.B. beim Melken.
Sie haben eine App programmiert, um
die Milchmenge jeder Kuh zu notieren.
Das gab es hier vorher nicht.
Auch sonst haben sie Dinge verändert.
Z.B. haben sie alle Fensterscheiben
aus dem Stall entfernt,
damit mehr Luft zirkuliert.
Für die Bauern und Besitzer der Kühe
ist das speziell.
Wenn sie nichts sagen,
weiss man meist nicht so richtig,
was sie davon halten.
Ich gehe davon aus,
dass es schon okay ist,
aber dass vielleicht nicht alle so
happy sind, dass wir es so machen.
Weil ...
Früher war man es sich halt gewöhnt,
dass die Kühe warm haben.
Dass sie nicht frieren
und niemals Durchzug haben.
Ich glaube, davon sind wir
ein bisschen weggekommen,
wir sagen eher, sie können das schon
aushalten. Das liegt schon drin.
Du glaubst das oder du weisst das?
Ich ... glaube das.
Aha.
- Mhm.
* Livio lacht. *
Nach bestem Wissen und Gewissen.
Nach dem Melken ist es Zeit,
die Kühe aufs Feld zu schicken.
* Dumpfes Klopfen *
Hallo?
Damit sie ein bisschen
in die Gänge kommen,
ist hier jeden Morgen Partystimmung.
- Voilà und Wiederholung.
* Laute Technomusik
mit treibenden Bässen setzt ein. *
Komm! Hoi, hoi, hoi!
Kommt, aufstehen, aufstehen!
* Laute Kuhglocken, Technobeat *
Aufstehen, aufstehen!
Beim Rauslaufen
fällt eine hinkende Kuh auf.
Als Älpler sind sie dafür verantwort-
lich, dass es den Tieren gutgeht.
Und eben auch für ihre Pflege,
dafür haben sie gewisse Medikamente.
Aber zuerst müssen sie rausfinden,
was hier das Problem ist.
Das mag sie nicht.
Man könnte sie dort reintun.
- Dort rein? Ja.
Auf die Weide der Hinkebeine.
Dort kommt sie jetzt hin.
* Muhen, laute Kuhglocken *
Komm.
Wir lassen sie über den Tag
mal dort und schauen, wie es geht.
Und dann?
Vielleicht holen wir sie dann in
den Pedicurestand, den Klauenstand,
um zu sehen, ob sie einen Stein
oder so zwischen den Hufen hat.
Oder ob sie sich einfach
den Fuss vertreten hat oder so.
* Idyllische Alpenklänge *
Sobald hier die Sonne aufgeht,
ist es Alpromantik pur.
Und für sie ist es 4 Std. nach
dem Aufstehen, Zeit für Frühstück.
Nach zwei Monaten
hat sich ein Rhythmus eingependelt.
Ganz anders als in den ersten Tagen,
als die Bauern
ihre Kühe abgegeben hatten
und die Älpler
plötzlich allein waren.
Ich kann mich schon noch daran
erinnern, wie wir das erste Mal ...
Da haben wir es allein gemacht.
- ... zu zweit alleine gemolken,
alles alleine fertig gemacht
und hier oben gefrühstückt haben.
Das war schon noch ...
Das war schon speziell, ja.
Anfangs braucht es ein bisschen.
- Wir hatten schon ein wenig Mühe.
Sie reden immer von Kuhnamen,
aber wir kennen die doch nicht.
Wir kennen nur die Kuhnummer.
Platz XY.
Dann reden sie von einer Kuh ...
"Fargi."
Ja, Fargi. Hilf mir.
Wo steht sie? Welche Nummer?
"Ja, ihr Zahlenmenschen."
- Rot? Grün? Blau?
Für uns natürlich völlig ... Bei
70 Kühen und 50 weiteren Namen ...
* Er ahmt Explosionsgeräusche nach. *
Die beiden leben
ein paar Minuten vom Stall entfernt -
für Alpverhältnisse relativ luxuriös.
Über der Käserei
haben sie eine Wohnung -
ziemlich modern,
mit allem Drum und Dran.
Die Schuhe musst du nicht ausziehen,
komm rein. - Wirklich? - Ja.
Der Eingangsbereich. Es ist alles
sehr pragmatisch eingerichtet.
Es ist genug Komfort,
aber kein Luxus.
Die Küche ...
- Was, kein Luxus?
Eine so luxuriöse Alp?
- Das stimmt.
* Raffi lacht. *
Nein, weisst du, es ist nicht ...
Wie sagt man dazu?
Es ist kein Luxushotel an sich.
Wir haben eine Waschmaschine,
einen Geschirrspüler ...
Das Coolste für eine Alp ist schon
die funktionierende, gute Dusche.
Ja, wirklich super.
- Wenn es wirklich heiss wird.
Das kann man sich am Ende
eines langen Tages schon gönnen.
Stell dich kurz da rein,
dann kannst du reinkommen.
Ca. 1'000 l Milch werden hier
täglich zu Käse verarbeitet.
Das Schmieren ist nur ein Punkt auf
einer endlos scheinenden To-do-Liste.
Fangen wir an ...
- Oh, scheisse, schau hier.
... auf eine Art.
- Wir haben noch ordentlich Arbeit.
Rein körperlich
haben wir es schon gemerkt.
Man merkt die Bewegungen,
hier z.B. im Rücken.
Das merkt man schon, aber
es war nicht unbedingt schmerzhaft,
sondern eher ...
... dass man endlich wieder merkt,
dass man etwas macht.
Man spürt den Körper
auf eine gesunde Art.
Während sie mit dem Käse beschäftigt
sind, treffe ich ihren Chef,
den Kassier der Alpgenossenschaft,
die sie eingestellt hat.
Er ist sehr zufrieden mit ihnen.
Gibst du ihnen noch Fleisch,
oder was?
Ich lege ihnen ab und zu
etwas in den Kühlschrank.
Das ist für die beiden?
- Ja.
So hält man die Leute bei Laune.
Gute Arbeit, gute Dinge.
Ich habe gehört, dass Anfang Saison
ein Artikel in einer Zeitung war,
über einen Älpler, der abgehauen ist,
weil "kein Bier da war".
Die Jungs erzählten, du hättest einen
Tag später eine Kiste Bier gebracht.
Nur um sicher zu sein.
- Das war Zufall.
War das Zufall?
Ja, das war Zufall.
Was machst du, um Leute gut ...
Weisst du, damit sie glücklich sind?
Schwierig zu sagen.
Aber ich versuche, ihnen hier
eine gute Einrichtung zu bieten.
Ich meine, das haben wir hier.
Ein schöner Stall,
eine anständige Wohnung.
Und ...
... dann muss man
mit den Leuten umgehen können.
Ja.
Aber mal ein Zeichen,
dass man zufrieden ist ...
Das kann man
auf verschiedene Arten machen.
Eben, mal einen Kasten Bier bringen.
Leute haben ihre Alpzeit
hier auch schon abgebrochen.
Das höre ich während meiner Recherche
nicht zum ersten Mal.
Es ist halt nicht ohne,
dieser Job dort oben.
Auch Beat und Raffi haben Tage, an
denen sie überhaupt keine Lust haben
und lieber im Bett
liegen bleiben würden.
Aber das geht halt nicht. Dafür
gibt es jeweils einen Mittagsschlaf.
Ein Strohbett oder ein Heubett.
So ...
Ein Infinity-Bett
könnte man es auch nennen.
So ...
Gute Nacht.
* Livio lacht. *
So.
* Ächzen *
Es ist eine der wenigen Pausen,
die sie sich am Tag gönnen.
Sonst sind sie
die ganze Zeit auf Achse,
von morgens um 4 Uhr
bis 18 oder 19 Uhr.
Freizeit haben sie hier wenig.
Wir haben alle
ein Nickerchen gemacht.
Wenn man so früh aufstehen muss,
ist das wohl nicht ungesund.
Ich glaube,
die Jungs sind schon wach.
Ich glaube, jetzt ist es schon Zeit,
um oben die Kühe zu holen,
damit sie
wieder gemolken werden können.
Ich habe langsam den Dreh raus,
wie es auf der Alp funktioniert.
(Leise) Fünf, sechs, acht, neun,
zehn, elf, zwölf, 13, 14, 15, 16.
* Leichtes Keuchen *
Ja, schau an! Hallo zusammen!
Das sind eben die Wohlerzogenen.
Die kommen von selbst?
- Ja, das sind meine.
Wie lange hat das gedauert,
bis du sie kennengelernt hast?
Puh ... Die Kühe oder die Orte?
Beides. Für dich ist ja beides neu.
- Ja.
Äh, die Kühe ...
Die Kühe, das ist wahrscheinlich
wie die Lehrer in der Schule.
Die Problemfälle kennt man schnell.
Dann sind es die dort hinten.
Ich glaube, die Einzelkinder
sind wieder halbhoch.
Eins, zwei, drei, vier ...
Heya, hopp!
Hopp!
* Kuhglocken *
Ich soll
die Whatsapp-Nachricht lesen.
"Eine Rote,
acht Gelbe, sechs Blaue."
Eine Rote, acht Gelbe, sechs Blaue.
Es sind jeweils ein paar Kilometer,
die man hier zurücklegt.
Da würden aber noch fehlen ...
Da überlegt man sich gut, ob man alle
Kühe hat, um nicht zweimal zu gehen,
v.a. bei Regen, Nebel oder Hagel.
Alles schon passiert.
Gemütlich ist anders.
Ich sehe nur ungefähr zehn.
Es müssten 15 sein,
dann würden fünf fehlen.
Das kann ich fast nicht glauben,
die sind sicher schon unterwegs.
Die Einzelkinder habe ich, ja.
Sie laufen sogar, ja.
Gut, ciao!
Es könnte doch noch sein,
dass wir nochmal ausrücken dürfen.
Wie man meiner Frisur ansieht,
war es anstrengend.
Das ist nur der Wind. Das ist
der Wind, nichts ist anstrengend.
Für dich vielleicht nicht,
du bist das gewöhnt. Aber ...
Es ist windig.
Jetzt bin ich auch gespannt,
ob wir alle haben.
Haha, whoohoo!
Etwas, was an diesem Job
für beide sehr cool ist:
Man sieht sofort
die Resultate der Arbeit.
In ihrem normalen Job als Ingenieure
sei das überhaupt nicht so.
Deshalb auch dieses Time-out -
weit weg vom Alltag.
Geschafft,
aber wir haben es geschafft.
Es war doch noch
ein ereignisreicher Tag.
Es passiert einfach
immer wieder etwas.
Man denkt,
es wird ein kurzer Tag und dann ...
... nichts Spezielles.
- ... wird es trotzdem wieder lang.
Das ist schon so.
Ich weiss,
es ist noch zu früh für eine Bilanz.
Es sind erst zwei von drei Monaten.
Aber wie schaut ihr
auf diese Zeit zurück?
Neun von zehn.
- Neun von zehn?
Ich würde eher sagen ...
Ein bisschen stolz, dass wir es
bis jetzt gut hingekriegt haben
und keinen Streit hatten.
Sehr viel Ehrfurcht.
Wir haben das Glück
ja ein bisschen erzwungen,
indem wir ausgewählt
und uns vorbereitet haben.
Das kann man schon sagen.
- Es sagen auch immer alle:
"Oh, dann kommst du
auf den Boden der Tatsachen."
Ja. Aber ...
Wir haben es ja gesucht.
Also ich habe es
schon ein bisschen gesucht.
Den Boden der Tatsachen?
Ich wollte nicht auf die Heidi-Alp,
um Ziegen zu streicheln.
Wenn ich so zurückschaue,
weiss ich noch,
wie ich am ersten Morgen, als alles
losging, beim Aufstehen dachte:
Puh.
Kommt das gut?
Und ...
- Ja.
Es ging.
Ja, tatsächlich.
* Volksmusik *
Tags darauf sind die Kühe schon auf
und davon, bis ich im Stall ankomme.
Monja, die hinkende Kuh von gestern,
muss genauer untersucht werden -
im sog. Klauenstand.
Eine Prozedur, die für alle Invol-
vierten nicht gerade entspannend ist.
Komm. Hey.
So.
Man merkt schon,
dass du helfen kannst. - Ja, mega.
Ich habe
ca. drei Youtubevideos geschaut.
Wirklich?
* Beat lacht. *
Man findet alles auf Youtube,
so krass.
* Scheppern *
Uah.
Wir können einfach mal den Spray
draufmachen, aber ...
Einfach nicht zu grob.
- Ja, ja.
Nein, hey, hey.
- Hey, hey, hey!
(Beruhigend) Ja ...
Alles wird gut.
- Wir lassen dich gleich raus.
Vorsichtig sollte man schon sein.
Und gerade bei Klauen ...
Ich habe da keine Erfahrung.
Und Beat ...
... hat natürlich ein bisschen mehr,
aber ...
Es ist wichtig zu wissen,
wo die Grenzen sind.
Nicht etwas versuchen, was ...
... man überhaupt nicht
im Griff hat.
Damit tut man
niemandem einen Gefallen.
Weisst du denn, wo die Grenze ist?
- Ich hoffe es.
Ich hoffe es.
Jetzt wird es kalt.
Wir überschätzen uns
nicht derart selbst,
dass wir das Gefühl hätten,
wir könnten das alles.
Aber Achtung, sie springt dann.
- Ja, ja.
Nein, nicht einmal.
Ja.
Ich habe sie nicht angebunden.
- Du hast gut hingehalten.
Warte!
Ich habe sie nicht angebunden.
So.
- Lässt du sie raus?
Dann räume ich hier auf.
- Schau, wie happy sie jetzt ist.
Sie geht wie eine Prinzessin.
* Raffi lacht. *
Erfolg!
Heute verzichten Raffi und Beat
auf einen Mittagsschlaf.
Bei diesem Wetter haben sie eine
bessere Idee: Gleitschirm fliegen.
Es ist nicht so oft passiert
wie erhofft.
Aber manchmal muss man sich
die Zeit einfach nehmen.
So viel zum Thema Schoggijob
auf der Alp. Nein.
Nein, ich merke schon,
dass es kein Schoggijob ist.
Das glaube ich euch,
ich sehe es euch auch an.
Weisst du, ich merke, dass es
ein Marathon und kein Sprint ist,
auf der Alp zu arbeiten.
Oder? Jeden Tag aufzustehen,
jeden Tag zack-zack.
Schon, ja.
- Aber, wie soll ich sagen?
Vielleicht ist es auch, weil ich
nur zwei, drei Tage hier bin
und euch bei der Arbeit nur zuschaue.
Dass es auf mich etwas einfacher
wirkt, auch wenn der ganze ...
... Umgang mit den Tieren und so ...
Das wäre für mich schon härter,
als dass ich mir das
überhaupt vorstellen könnte.
Ich glaube schon, dass ...
Der Umstand, dass man das
nicht nur zwei, drei Tage macht,
sondern wirklich eine Woche,
dann eine zweite, eine dritte Woche.
Und wieder und wieder und wieder.
- Ja.
Die Summe des Ganzen
macht schon einiges aus.
Man muss wirklich Ausdauer zeigen.
Man muss damit umgehen können, dass
es morgens manchmal monoton ist.
Dass man immer wieder
dasselbe macht.
Das braucht schon Ausdauer.
Aber für uns
ist es ein endliches Abenteuer.
D.h., wir sehen auch das Ende.
Das lässt zu, dass wir diese
Monotonie etwas geniessen können.
(Leise)
Ich finde es schon noch wichtig.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Euch zwei einen guten Flug.
(Aus der Ferne) Was sagst du?
- Einen guten Flug. - Danke.
Bis gleich.
* Idyllische Alpenklänge *
* Jubelschrei *
* Jubel *
Während sie in der Luft sind,
ist für mich der Moment gekommen, um
mich von der Belalp zu verabschieden.
Es war schön, muss ich sagen.
Die Romantik hat mich gecatcht,
aber ich muss natürlich sagen,
ich habe dort oben nur die schönsten
Momente gesehen. Schönes Wetter ...
Ich musste bei der Arbeit nur
zuschauen, das macht es einfacher.
Aber man muss schon sagen -
das sagen die beiden auch -,
dass es eine privilegierte Alp ist.
Die Wolfsthematik
ist z.B. nicht so präsent.
Oder auch das Thema
Trockenheit auf der Alp,
wovon andere Alpen
viel mehr betroffen sind.
Und es ist modern hier.
Es gibt Wasser und Strom.
Logisch, mit einer Käserei
braucht man das heutzutage.
Sie haben sich das schon klug
ausgewählt, auf so eine Alp zu gehen
und nicht eine im hintersten Winkel
ohne Wasser und ohne Strom.
Aber ich habe wirklich gelernt,
dass man es nicht unterschätzen darf.
Die Verantwortung
und die Arbeitsbelastung sind krass.
Hundert Tage lang jeden Tag um 4 Uhr
morgens auf der Matte zu stehen
und den ganzen Tag von einer
Baustelle zur nächsten zu rennen ...
Das ist schon eindrücklich.
Ich glaube, diese Arbeit
ist wirklich nicht zu unterschätzen.
Das war's von "rec." über das Leben
auf der Alp. Bis zum nächsten Mal.